thank you very much
good morning everybody and first we will
have an emergency evacuation
announcement should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building via the nearest
available exit to the chamber our
assembly point will be in the public
carpark at the side of the Civic suite
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note that this meeting is audio
recorded may I ask you all to turn
offshore telephones we'll put them onto
silent thank you morning my name is
councillor Arthur Williams I'm chairman
of the committee this morning the other
members are I would like to introduce
you to on my far right
I'm councillor Dave spurring Thank You
councillor Jo McPherson thank you very
much to receive any declarations of
interest please sorry first of all I do
apologize
and the committee legal adviser is mr.
Chris oh thank you I apologize to
receive any declarations of interest mr.
chairman just to make you aware that as
part of the consultation process Russia
District Council are one the responsible
authorities that can agree conditions or
proposed conditions I'd like to bring to
your attention on the appendix 3.1
condition eight and nine has been
proposed by Roger District Council from
the licensing team just bring it to your
attention I said it's not a greed
condition obviously they're open to
yourselves to decide wherever they are
suitable or not but they certainly were
ones that we have consulted with the
applicant takes one thank you very much
are there any other declarations of
interest in queue the committee will
follow the procedures set out in the
procedural note on item three of the
agenda and the purpose of today's
hearing is to determine an application
of
premises license has detailed in the
report please could the applicants
introduce themselves
Robert Cruikshank are the director of
apps and hold events limited Charlotte
offered resident okay thank you
do you have any witnesses that you wish
to cool oh sorry that is Charlotte sure
sorry Charlotte is the witness okay
thank you thank you could the council's
licensee officer please introduce
himself good morning I'm Stephen greener
I'm the watcher Council licensing
officer
could the premises license holder please
introduce themselves you're one of the
same yeah I'm one in the same yeah
Robert Cruikshank again director of app
to hold events limited okay
the other interested parties could we
have your sorry Robert Saints registered
thank you very much
are there any responsible authorities
present I don't think there are I don't
think we have any responsible
authorities present no do you have any
witnesses that you wish to call no sir
thank you
each party will be given a maximum of 15
minutes to present their submissions all
parties who make some representations
are given two minutes to make a closing
statement at the end of the hearing time
limits will only be extended with the
permission of the subcommittee please
could mr. greener summarize the
application
good morning again this is a report that
introduces an application for the grant
of a premises license made under Section
17 of the Licensing Act the application
must be determined within five working
days of the conclusion of the hearing in
accordance with paragraph 26 of the
licensing act 2003 hearings regulations
2005 this application is submitted to
the licensing authority by the applicant
absent all events limited and refers to
the premises that is known as absent
halt absent all absent hauled Road
Rochet Essex Appendix A which has been
invited to you is a copy of the original
application that was submitted at the
time the premises to which the
application relates comprised of a
wedding and function venue with
overnight accommodation for bed and
breakfast and the premises is located in
a quiet area of ruptured and we've also
included in Appendix B a map to help you
actually identify where the location is
the application is for the following
licensable activities and the times it
is all exactly the same Monday to Sunday
10 a.m. to 1 a.m. of the following day
for the sale of alcohol on and off the
premises provision of plays provisions
of films which is the live music
provision of recording music
performances of dance and finally
provisions of late night refreshment
that does actually start from 2300 so it
starts me at 11 o'clock at night until 2
o'clock the following morning that's the
only difference I have also asked for a
seasonal variation as well in relation
to New Year's Eve Valentine's Day
Halloween Christmas Eve and all Fridays
and Saturdays on bank holidays to extend
the last selectivities for an additional
hour the application was made in
accordance with section 17 jul 8 1 and
paragraph 7 of the licensing Act and the
licensing acts 2003 premises license and
clubs certificates regulations 2005
prior to the application being submitted
the applicants have already previously
submitted 11 temporary event
applications which obvious basically
temporary licenses and they were sent to
Essex Police and the Environmental
Health Team and neither of them have
made any representations against any of
the 11 applications the application has
been assessed by environment to health
and they have not made any
representation Essex Police and Roger
District Council have agreed position
conditions with the applicant should you
feel that these are appropriate and to
be granted
appendix a as I mentioned earlier are a
copy of the conditions that have been
proposed by ourselves and Essex Police
there has been one representation
received from a local resident and the
representation raise concerns in
relation to the following licensing
objectives which is crime disorder and
public nuisance and a copy of the
representation again reserved in the
bundle under appendix D all parties
involved have been served with relevant
notices and documentation required by
paragraph 6 and 7 of the licensing act
here in regulations 2005 the notices and
documentation included an explanation of
the rights of the persons to attend the
hearing and to be represented and to
give evidence in to call witnesses
paragraphs eight and nine of the
regulations require that parties notify
the licensing authority no later than
five working days before the hearing of
those matters mentioned in paragraph
five one and a pro-forma was signed by
both parties and presented to us the
following options are available to the
members to grant the application
subjects to such conditions that are
consistent with the operating schedule
modify to such extent as members
considered necessary for promoting the
licensing objectives and any manage
preconditions that must be included to
exclude from the scope of the license
any license fortuitous which the
applicant relates to reject the
application and finally subject to
paragraphs 11 to 13 of the licensing act
2003 hearings regulation 2005 to adjourn
the hearing to a specified date or
arrange for a hearing to be held on
specific specified additional dates
where members consider it necessary for
the consideration of any representations
under a equality impact assessment there
has been found no impacts either
positive or negative on protected groups
as defined under the Equality Act and
the recommendation is for the
subcommittee to resolve the application
and that's the end of the report could
the premises license hold to present any
submissions that they may have please
sorry before we do that just ask the
committee if we have any questions for
mr. greener
no thank you
sorry could the premises license holder
the Apple 2 can present any submissions
they may have please oh sorry
do you have any questions for mr. green
now I don't miss much thank you all
right and okay do you have any questions
for mr. Brender the lemon
thank you
that's right thank you good morning
just some history on the background of
Acton Hall it's a family-run business
the Squires who are the owners of Acton
whole contacted mail by mutual friends
because they always knew that I didn't
want to run the business themselves
because they don't have the experience
to run a high-end venue and that's what
we was looking to achieve with Acton
Hall my background as an operator is 25
years or in excess of 25 years now of
event a venue management both in the UK
and in Europe both myself and my team
has always set higher standards and
quality of service at all time and we
continue to grow the team with training
and continued advancement the build of
Acton Hall took three to four years due
to the fact that we wanted to create a
high-end venue that fit really well into
the local market and it could be
something that Rochford can be proud of
and it was certainly something that we
felt as as a team that was missing in a
local area the investment has been quite
considerable to make it a high-end venue
and we've not under spent on stuff like
soundproofing in the main area to make
sure that the local residents are
affected we've had ongoing discussions
with local residents from the planning
application process straight through to
utilising the temporary events notices
as Stephen mentioned the police and
environmental health have not needed to
come down to decide at any stage we've
followed all the licensing guidelines as
I mentioned we've kept an open dialogue
with all the neighbors and if there has
been any issue
we've dealt with them straight away I
would say there's probably seven local
neighbors that are in within the sound
barrier ShareASale
of the the actual venue itself and none
of those have felt the need to come and
make a representation and in fact two of
those local residents actually went
against the planning application
initially and my aim was to prove that
within use in the temporal temporary
events notices that they didn't have any
concerns and they've actually turned
their decision round who actually
endorsed the venue now rather than be
against it when the planning application
went through as I said we've not had any
complaints from the Environmental Health
or the police we do have practices that
we send managers down to the bottom of
the chase to make sure that there's no
patrons at the bottom of the track chase
and we contained them in the courtyard
we also have a policy with taxi partners
where they only pick up in the courtyard
it had happen on one or two occasions or
maybe the first or second event that
unfortunately someone was picked up at
the bottom but we've rectified that now
and ever since then that doesn't happen
anymore the local taxi company is
Andrews they have strict instructions
not to flash their lights when entering
the venue or to sound the horn and to
only pick up guests inside the courtyard
and not on the roadside we also have a
system in place which I believe we are
the first venue within the Rochford
district to have an IVR system which
basically facilitates us to go to the
top of any taxi phone calls that are
made locally so basically it means that
we can get people off site as quick and
efficiently as possible during the
evening and once the evening is finished
as well going back to the high-end venue
we are a wedding venue we consider
ourselves as a wedding venue we've never
looked at us as a nightclub or anything
like that the process of the the the
stages of the day is very food
orientated so therefore it's not
somewhere that people just go and drink
and drink and drink and there is a lot
of food on-site which keeps down any
boisterous attitude should we say and I
have got one witness here with me today
I'm Charlotte offered and she is one of
the closest neighbors to the venue
I don't know [ __ ] asked Charlotte to
speak now is that possible
that will be fine
let's give me a second sorry
I think professor professor welcome to
the committee you have to ask any
questions first if have you finished all
yeah that's if we could just ask if any
other committee members have any
questions you have some okay yeah we
listen to your witness within the
confines and it should on that basis
and in NATO mr. Sykes concerns picking
up at the junction they have something
that
so it's quite quite Easter and
complimented haften that
some issues of mr. Sykes's raise we'll
discuss later in the in the hearing
comes from the person
oh sorry can't get it win oh goody don't
worry
Thank You chairman um yes in the
recommendation to approve always got
about the taxi private hire booking
service so you would have to comply with
that anyway which again as counselors
Berrien mentioned addresses some of the
objectives concerns what I would like to
know is taxis aren't the only way that
these people are going to be picked up
they're being picked up I would by my
son for example if I was going so what
notifications are given to your
customers that pickup is from the
courtyard and not from the exit thank
you and we've actually got a sign by the
carpark that actually says pickup point
which points in the direction that the
courtyard itself we also highlight in
advance to the bride and groom to let
them know that call the courtyard is the
only pickup point when people come there
is also mini buses that turn up because
we've also got a partnership with
Holiday Inn and so there's quite a few
shuttle runs for people staying at the
Holiday Inn as well and also in terms of
families picking up for disabled or
anyone like that they actually pick up
in the courtyard so everything is driven
prior to the event prior to the weddings
and on the day at a weddings to the
courtyard that is the pickup point
because in the courtyard is obviously
shelter of the the buildings as well so
it alleviates any noise problems there
we go just following on from that term
with your staff you mentioned that you
send some down there would it be an idea
therefore if you've got a large event to
have somebody there as cars pull up they
actually are waving them into the
courtyard and also stopping people from
going down to the edge of the road be
picked up absolutely and that's
something we actually again with the
scoring matrix of each event we
determine how many people are coming to
that
then and how many staff we need on-site
to actually say okay this one's going to
be quite a few cars coming therefore
we'll have a car park attendant who
stays on site until people leave and the
management structure of actually walking
down to the bottom of the chase or the
actual entrance was more determined on
noise pollution as well so but the
actual staffing levels are maintained
for out the day to make sure nobody does
walk down to the chase you know on
occasions one or two people do slip in
it but we are running it straight to way
to go down there and bring them back up
to the Courtyard I have a couple of
questions I have y'all does that stand
for for the taxi
I'm glad you asked me that and yeah it's
basically a system that I'm not very
technical so I do apologize with this
and I don't know what IVR stands for
molix but basically the system is that
we have three different mobile phones
that basically go through to their
switchboard ie Andrews and AC taxis and
then the switchboard recognizes our
mobile number called and it gives them
priority so that goes straight to the
top of the list and as I said that is we
are the only venue in Rochford currently
that actually has that facility in place
okay um I I drove past a couple of days
here to have a look around before we
came here today there are a couple of
lodges there a pair of lodges at either
side of the chase I believe are they
occupied yes one's occupied by mr.
Saints and the opposite one's occupied
by Melanie Hall and she's actually sent
me a letter and because she can come due
to ill health but basically she has no
representations against it either are
they going to be maintained as
residential premises and you would have
to ask these Squires for that because I
don't have any and it's not part of my
and venue
it will each other one of the other
issues I have is regarding the
late-night refreshments I believe it is
when you say like late-night
refreshments so you're asking for that
to finish it two o'clock is that right
that's correct that's only for specific
events most weddings will be 12:00
midday up to 12:00 midnight but but with
honor you're asking for it to be
extended to for an hour
what specific occasions yes so those
specific occasions will be New Year's
Eve specific for your IP event should we
should we have anything like that oh
that's potentially 3:00 in the morning
oh no it would only no it was it was one
o'clock with an extra hour so it would
be two o'clock but it wouldn't be free
o'clock okay on the application use that
does actually ask that finishes an hour
after as far as I'm aware who is that
correct
[Music]
I say to any seasonal variations for the
provision of late notice freshmen steady
by an hour so that would be that would
include the hour
sorry
so that that's one page 1.17 yeah so
you've got it here as two o'clock so
that would not be going on until three
in the morning or now wouldn't now two
o'clock East efficient so if that
includes yesterday so if that was to be
brought into conditions that wouldn't be
an issue at all no not at all thank you
very much thank you for that I don't
believe I have you had any complaints up
till now from residents now complaints
from residents and no complaints from
police or environmental health
thank you the other yeah there was one
other issue well do you plan on having
it I know that somebody a friend is
coming in next week for a wake do you
plan on doing any other types of events
here for instance raves absolutely not
right my background used to be stuff
like that and I now got my family and I
couldn't think of anything worse hence
one of the reasons I moved that here and
really this is a progression of what my
professional background is so weddings
are the sole business really so and
birthday parties things like that would
you do who's not going to be considered
and I know not birthday parties don't
want to do any birthday parties to be
honest the venue the way we structured
the venue and design the venue it's
heavily based around a three-course meal
with entertainment and to be frank that
is what the venue will be driven with as
a business and you mentioned wakes with
actually got awake and next week again
food and drink as such but we will not
be entertaining any events that are just
solely drink driven because it goes back
to what I said it's not a nightclub and
that's not what we want we want
longevity for the
you we believe there is a gap in the
market for a wedding venue a high-end
wedding venue and today with the success
of the south I don't think we will need
to entertain any birthday parties all
alike what brings that to mind is places
like the lawns for instance have wedding
days all sorts of other things going on
there to be fair there generally during
the day they're not in them and and
things like Car Classic Car Shows you
don't have any intentions or anything
like that
I think that's excessive apt in whole
today with in terms of sales there's no
need for us to do that and it's not
really a place that would work to do
those car shows etc because we haven't
we're limited with the area that we've
got and so this only wouldn't be any
need to do any big shows outside of of
the venue itself the core venue in the
core business is based around a
courtyard buildings and so we've never
really felt the need to do anything on
the paddock or anywhere else and again
being a wedding venue you want to try
and keep the greenery and landscape of a
higher level and something of that ilk
would probably go be detrimental against
the core business which is obviously the
wedding business you know you have a
barrier at the end of the draw of the
choices is it I think is that going to
remain down it that most times all work
we prepare to enter all is it is there
anything to come there the idea is that
again with budgets next year we've
budgeted to be able to bring the
ancients forward to where the actual
lodges are and the new gate will
actually be a disappearing gate into the
ground and that will also have intercom
and additional CCTV on that will that
have any impact on the view of the road
leaving the premises now it's set back
far enough
I'm sure a muchness all I need to ask um
do any other parties have any questions
yes it's not at the moment thank you
very much
[Music]
could the interested party present any
submissions that they may have this is
your turn
sorry yeah I do apologize you're in here
if you wouldn't mind every lovely I just
like that's what you don't understand
this way
oh I I was just gonna introduce
Charlotte offered she's one of the local
residents literally probably 10 10
meters 10 meters from the entrance of
apps and hallways that we noticed and if
you're so we in will cottage we she said
I was almost dead opposite the entrance
to absent hall and we did initially put
in an objection when the planning first
went in for the wedding venue really
isn't because we would conserve one of
the noise and secondly we're vehicles
were leaving the premises
they almost point directly into the
front of our property from that
objection absent all were very good in
listening to all of our comments all
through the planning process of the
building we had regular meetings regular
visits with them discussions about how
to keep things so that it didn't impact
on our lives and before the venue was
even opened we were invited to a
soundcheck whereby we all started at the
end of the chase and walked up to the
and until we actually entered the
archway of the courtyard we could not
hear any noise from the sound systems at
the venue when we opened the doors I
couldn't believe that we couldn't hear
anything down the line the DJ had
actually put it on the loudest possible
settings of the systems for us to be
able to tell the difference we couldn't
hear anything since the actual events
have started taking place to be honest
the only way we've known is because
after every event Robb's knocked on our
door to make sure there was no problems
and we weren't disturbed we didn't have
any issues that it needed to be brought
to his attention I've not noticed any
cars really coming in and out the
driveway
obviously you notice certain because
you've seen the wedding cards going but
if I wasn't so nosy I probably wouldn't
see them and I've certainly not heard
any loud noises I actually hear more
from the Garen's events than what I do
from absent Hall I've not noticed any
people loitering and we've certainly not
been disturbed at all by the wedding
venue and myself and my husband have no
objections to venue itself or the
premises being got into its license
thank you very much thank you that's
helpful and could the interested party %
any submissions they may have unless mr.
Saints I believe and we have one letter
of objectionable it was as there is no
address on it
I believe this this was yours and you
live in one of the lodges at the end of
live directly next door on the first
neighbor next to the venue thank you so
that's how far away would you say from
the venue at the end of the driveway but
on their first night bath yeah a couple
of hundred yards I'm not very good at
numbers okay
distances but I'm that the first person
on the first house that you need to be
connected to before
Charlotte's or mrs. holes I'm direct
line the first neighbor you're actually
one of the lodgers
I am the lodgers as you come in on the
first one it's marked on the map but
it's sort of disingenuous it's it's not
actually marked down that this is
Western Lodge but that's where I live
it's kind of in a restrictive that and
slowly Albert good morning thank you for
your time
cancellous i resided action hall for
four years this December in 2015
renovation began and is continued at
this very moment in time during this
period of time I have had no discussions
with absent hall events regarding their
venue or venue or venture I live in the
gatehouse that is at the entrance of
action Hall events I'm the closest
neighbor as he's indicated on the map
I'm directly and continually impacted by
the vents held there in mr. Locke's on
stake declaration he states that he has
had dialogue with the neighbors positive
feedback and a visit an ongoing dialogue
with them this has not happened in
instance with me as the first number not
once I have seen no evidence I've seen
no evidence of security a nor security
implementation I have witnessed vile
drunken and drug-induced behavior I
witness public exposure and public
indecency it has only been recently the
absent all signage has been on display
prior to this many visitors would knock
on my door and ask for directions or
clarifications as to where absent Hall
actually is this is upsetting it caps
its well-being and magnifies anxieties
they do have an electronic gate which
only in the past fortnight or so has
displayed a phone number to call for the
code to interact and halt events up
until now they go stays shut and
visitors must queue and back up towards
the main rate main road which is a 60
miles an hour Road this is potentially
dangerous and shows a lack of care and
respect of their guests this is still
ongoing as recently as Wednesday evening
since the signage has been in place
Acton Hall has now become a named
meeting place where all manners of
nefarious characters meet congregate and
conduct business directly outside the
front of my residence the road as I for
mentioned is 60 miles an hour the
entrance to absent Hall is rather
concealed but access it is but the exit
is extremely dangerous to the unknowing
the exit from Acton Hall onto Acton haul
road is perilous especially - if if you
do not know the whereabouts of the road
and I truly have daily fear of a serious
accident occurring unless steps are
taken to address this dangerous issue
and again it shows a lack of respect and
understands towards the guests and the
wider community as it states in the
licensing declaration the area is a
quiet part of Rockford that is the
reason for me to live here I have no
issue with the current license but I
have seen no evidence who would justify
this further extension up until now I
have not witnessed behavior or conduct
which could justify this license
application being granted absent Hall
events has shown a great lack of
professionalism I have been involved in
for over 35 years in Events Management
and I would not recommend this company
nor endorse it nor warn at this extended
license it is clear that the idea sold
of Acton Hall has sadly not come to
fruition and therefore the company is
attempting to deviate and rebound from a
wedding venue venture and re-emerge as a
new creature entirely with an extended -
am license this has been extremely
detrimental to my health and well-being
I've seen two families moved on in
interest of transparency I - and being
currently threatened with eviction and
homelessness so the gatehouse I reside
in can be converted into a office that
absent hall events
I suffer from Crohn's disease and a
depressive episode I've been bullied
harassed victimized and slandered even
to the point of sorting my
eight-year-old parents address and hand
delivering a complaint about me to them
the day after I made my representation
it was a farm that was also a building
site and a failing win of you that now
needs to become function as a seven-day
exempt it's ended until am licensed the
day after my name was released as the
individual maker representers and while
suffering from an acute attack of
Crohn's disease I was harassed from ten
to ten fifteen by continual banging and
knocking on the front door front and
side windows to rouse me which is
obviously correlation and
the bullying victimization of a sick man
with a lifelong condition I had as a
sailor I have no objection to the
temporary license and indeed would be
happy to see it continue
I do respectfully ask though and request
that this further extended license is
denied thank you we're ago Thank You mr.
Saints first of all I'm very sorry to
hear about your poor health
unfortunately this is also a licensing
meeting so we can only take in licensing
issues so one thing I will address you
mentioned the exert the imperialists
that again is not a licensing issue I'm
afraid that's a highways issue I will
hopefully go back to and the applicant
and query because you're saying you have
not had mr. Cruikshank visit you or
converse with you now couple of issues
and you said that you've seen
drug-induced behavior how do you know
that that was drug-induced behavior
cultural parties and have sometimes like
deviate away and do drugs publicly not
only that I've had patrons of the right
and taken in your experience and how
important this is especially around
events you will have reported this to
the police
I'm ever so sorry mr. Saints there is
one thing that I'm I do have concerns of
if you witness and you know that there's
drug induced behavior drug being dealt
at all that is a police matter
and you're saying none of these have
been reported to the police regarding
this because we have had eleven
apparently events held there with no
reports from the police at all
it is mr. site and you're telling me
that you're experienced in events I
would know how important that is to
report to the police
and yet we have representation from the
police on the last 11 events that there
have been no reports okay thank you
[Music]
the exposure was that to urinate I
presume and this was on on the site
itself
we'll ask the applicant to come back on
that one yeah just two if you do have an
issue it is important that you report
this to 101 or online
otherwise the police don't know there's
an issue I presume from what you're
saying is that you are a tenant of the
squire's
that's correct thank you thank you very
much
first of all right do it I'd like to ask
the applicant now if you'd like to ask
any questions of our objector you
mentioned in your evidence that people
have been knocking on your door and I've
been personally trying knock on your
door for quite some time of which you've
never answered and there was absolutely
no reason for me to go to six other
neighbors and then not include you into
it there is no personal vendetta against
you it would just not make any business
sense to not include you so I have been
to your premises on numerous occasions
knocked on the door and you have not
answered your door
whether that's down to your illness I
don't know but attempts have been made
on several occasions to include you to
the process of keeping the neighbors on
site can I just ask you
for questions to the objects not to make
a statement at this stage then I have no
questions thank you so much does the
premises license hold that the applicant
have any closing statements they would
like to make and do you mind if I stay
another time and
this is probably the 12th or 13th thing
you have opened over a history of 25
plus years there is always a process to
gaining the neighbors approval for the
longevity of any venue the processes and
protocols that we've put in place have
made it easier for the local neighbors
to come on board
I'm very amazed and quite frankly
bewildered that mr. Saints has given
this evidence when there's nobody else
representing from six or seven other
neighbors I'm unaware of
anyone that's moved jutted it to the
fact that Acton Hall was being built I
have neighbors who have turned round and
and changed their attitude towards the
venue based on going against the
planning I think that's proven and as
far as moving forward we will continue
to improve I will make sure my team does
additional training and we will not stop
trying to improve the team and the way
we conduct business I don't agree at all
with mr. Saints representation and as
I've said before if it was as severe
then there would be other neighbors here
representing as well as mr. Saints thank
you very much thank you do you have a
closing statement that you'd like to
make indeed I do
in answer to mr. Cruikshank the
neighbors who haven't complained
directly opposite of the filth or
mentioned mrs. hall her husband has a
vested interest we've been working for
the Events Management he does long Irene
within the square like he said directly
working for after the hall events but he
does work within ask wise Oh
no a number of neighbors that who they
have gone over and tried to curry favor
with them and I'm quite surprised that I
managed to get Charlotte here today
however Charlotte does not live Russia
lives across the road from there but I
live directly there and also and I don't
mean to be speak out of terms the lady
aforementioned lady has a severe
alcoholic problem so she and I don't
want to highlight that or anything like
that but so she may not be able to see
okay that's not a problem so however I
am the director I'm the direct niver
if mr. Cruikshank could not go at me by
banging on my door as he said he could
have written me could have left a note
there are many ways to get in touch with
me not just by banging on the door the
fact that I've had to come here today to
have this discussion is because mr.
Cruikshank to mr. Loxton have adhered in
a responsibility as patrons of a venue
they've tried to circumvent a tenant
just to ask it just a great Ocarina
would like any any importance to fit in
this point
but if there were facilities in the
rooms that wouldn't need a license I
presume that would fall under laborers
Thank You own conclusion of the evidence
the committee will now adjourn to
consider the case we will return shortly
to announce the decision this will also
be sent to you in writing you do not
have to wait but you are welcome to do
so if you wish and thank you all for
attending thank you
[Music]
you see ready
thank you for waiting right the
committee has considered all the written
evidence and the representative
representations made at the hearing
today the committee has also carefully
considered the concerns raised by the
interested party relating to the Lea
licensing objective so it's the licensee
reject solve the prevention of crime and
disorder the prevention of public
nuisance
there have been no representative
representations from Essex Police or
Environmental Health in respect of this
application
representative representations have been
made from the applicant including
evidence from a witness who lives
opposite the venue and the interested
party the interested party has not
provided a evidence to support his
submissions regarding crime and disorder
and public nuisance we note that there
has been no objection for Essex Police
we are aware from the evidence that 11
temporary vent notices have taken place
at this venue and no reported concerns
have been made in respect of those 11
temporary event notices to Essex Police
or environmental health taking into
account all the above the committee who
resolved to grant the application as per
the agreed conditions contained within
the application along with the mandatory
conditions the committee reminds all
those present that if any problems arise
in the future as a result of the grant
of the license for review of the licence
can be requested at any time this
concludes today's hearing and a four
decision notice will be issued in due
course thank you all for attending